[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
philosophie diesmal aus berlin
und zwar mit einem der erfolgreichsten
deutschsprachigen schriftsteller unserer
zeit nämlich mit daniel kehlmann
sein roman die vermessung der welt war
ein weltbestseller
in seinem neuesten buch heftet er sich
an die fersen des gauklers till
eulenspiegel und durch reist mit ihnen
die grausame zeit des dreißigjährigen
krieges anlauf für uns über die rolle
des narren in unserer zeit nachzudenken
und zu fragen wer hält heute eigentlich
wen zumal ich freue mich sehr dass sie
hier sind daniel kümmern
ja sie überraschen mich immer wieder
nicht nur mit so großartigen bücher wie
dem wir über das ihr nachher gleich
sprechen sondern auch mit einem beitrag
kürzlich in der zeit indem sie die frage
aufgeworfen haben ob man nicht
vielleicht die venen boykottieren müsste
die ja ja es kam einfach dazu dass ich
ein buch rezensiert habe und das war ein
buch von klaus zeyringer und stefan
gmünder mit einem beitrag von ilja
trojanow und die autoren fassen da kurz
mal knapp und konzise und ruhig ohne wut
zusammen was wir eigentlich ohnehin
schon alles wissen nämlich diese
ungeheure korruption und nicht nur die
korruption sondern auch die sonst ganz
unakzeptablen bedingungen die die
weltmeisterschaft und die austragung von
weltmeisterschaften die art wie die fifa
das handhabt umfassen
und wenn man das so knapp liest und und
am schluss fordern die autoren diesen
rekord und sagen es gibt überhaupt nur
eine möglichkeit die diese diese diese
lage zu ändern
die fifa ist so mächtig weil alle sich
das immer im fernsehen ansehen und die
einzige möglichkeit etwas zu ändern ist
dass man muss sich das mal nicht mehr im
fernsehen ansieht und ich habe das nur
gesagt wenn man das liest dann fällt
einem schwer widersprechen genau das ist
dieses buch das runde leder sogar
rezensiert haben und haben sie sich
jetzt dran
ich muss dazu sagen der der fairness
halber für
mich ist es leicht mich daran zu halten
weil ich sowieso sehr selten fußball
schaue also insofern war ich auch sehr
vorsichtig nicht zu groß zu sagen und
jetzt ändere ich meine gewohnheiten und
und macht das nicht mehr
also das heißt ich halte mich vorwiegend
daran nicht ganz weil ich habe einen
neunjährigen sohn der sehr gerne fußball
sieht und ich will ihnen ja auch jetzt
nicht hängen lassen
das wollte ich sie nämlich auch noch
fragen wie sehr ihnen eigentlich am
fußball liegt weil sie immer einfacher
ist etwas zu kritisieren das richtig gar
nicht das ist richtig und das war dessen
war ich mir auch bewusst und beim beim
schreiben und ich habe nur gedacht ich
möchte trotzdem vielleicht ist man ja
auch dann auch die erde richtige darüber
zu sprechen über so ein buch zu sprechen
wenn man nicht zu den fanatischen
anhängern gehört aber vielleicht auch
nicht also aber ich dachte mir ja einer
einer sollte darüber sprechen und und
dieses buch ja wie viele habe ich das
buch rezensiert und ich dachte dann
vielleicht sind sie der richtige darüber
zu sprechen weil das ja schon fast schon
politisch unkorrekt ist in der zeit der
wm fußball nicht so toll zu finden oder
fifa nichts und wohl zu finden und als
schriftsteller genießt man ja vielleicht
so etwas wie eine narrenfreiheit ja ein
bisschen also das als schriftsteller ist
man natürlich eher dass es gibt von von
nassim taleb der dieses schöne buch der
schwarze schwan geschrieben hat genau
das wollte ich hinaus es gibt sein sein
buch danach riss an die fragilität und
er spricht über systeme die schwerer zu
erschüttern sind als andere
und was mich sehr gefreut hat ich weiß
gar nicht ob er recht hat aber sein
beispiel für anti fragilität im sozialen
leben sind tatsächlich schriftsteller
er sagt wenn ein schriftsteller mal
einigermaßen etabliert ist kann das ja
den ruf ruinieren
ich weiß nicht aber recht hat aber das
hört man natürlich gern
sie sind natürlich auf jeden fall
etabliert ich habe mich auch gefragt ob
ich die rolle des schriftstellers sich
verändert hat und vielleicht auch die
rolle des philosophen wenn ihr ein
bisschen zurück drehen dann frauen ein
ja schon beispiele ein von wirklich
närrischen philosophen als erasmus von
rotterdam zb mit seinem lob der torheit
der hat ja wirklich die inquisition denn
die kleriker in einer art und weise aufs
korn genommen wie das
ansonsten hätte tun dürfen ja natürlich
nietzsche auch wenn man wenn man so will
also das war ja auch sein sein ziel
philosophie aus dieser akademischen
an ihm kann man gar nicht sagen aus der
akademischen halle heraus zu holen und
zu etwas freiem und wildem und lustigem
auch zu machen so lustig ist nun gar
nicht mehr wenn wir heute lesen aber das
war sicher etwas was er wollte
philosophie ist spielt sich eben immer
auch ab in diesem zwiespalt eigentlich
seit der tradition von sokrates platon
und der akademie wenn man so will spielt
sich ab in diesem in diesem
spannungsfeld zwischen freiheit also
etwas was da ist der philosophie immer
der aus der gesellschaft austritt der
allen widerspricht der überhaupt
nirgendwo hineinpasst und der wild und
frei in alle richtungen denkt und auf
der anderen seite denen die das sofort
auch nicht zu unrecht unterrichten
wollen was er entdeckt hat und plötzlich
entstehen institutionen wird sich
entstehen regel unter denen diese
philosophie unterrichtet wird und diese
spannung zwischen zwischen akademie
akademie auf der einen seite und auf der
anderen seite dem dem dem absoluten
außenseiter der dann auch ein nachher
ist ja das spielt sich philosophie
darin spielt sie sofia und da ist gleich
der schriftsteller phraya war ja nicht
in der akademie ist normalerweise genau
das ist der schriftsteller ist eben ich
meine inzwischen gibt's natürlich schon
viele schriftsteller die auch irgendwo
professoren sind aber eigentlich ist der
schriftsteller der künstler überhaupt
ist freier als der akademische
philosophie und über diesen freigeist
aber eben auch über den norden möchte
ich mit ihnen sprechen und ich glaube
wir sollten wirklich mal anfangen mit
dem titel und diese figuren bisschen
kennenlernen das ist ja die zentrale
figur die dadurch diesen roman durch
geistert und auch eben durch den
dreißigjährigen krieg durch diese zeit
16 18 16 48 erzählen sie mal wer ist
also der historische teil ist jemand der
so nicht gab
ich muss dazu sagen weil ich immer
wieder jetzt mit lasern zu tun habe oder
oder eben auch gesprächspartnern die
glaube ich hätte eine historische figur
genommen und in der zeit verschoben aus
dem späten mittelalter in die frühe
neuzeit und
es gibt einen namen in einem
sterberegister der ein bisschen ähnlich
klingt wie www ulenspiegel aber
ansonsten gibt es keine historische
figur die ich in der zeit verlegt habe
sondern ich habe mich auf einen
anekdoten kreis gestützt der tatsächlich
ein bisschen älter ist der der aus dem
aus dem späten aus dem späten
mittelalter stammt und der umfasst der
eine asoziale figur namens gibt die
unterschiedlichen schreibweisen deal
ulenspiegel unter den spiegel oder till
eulenspiegel der sich eigentlich
normalerweise vor allem in kurzen
anekdoten enorm asozial verhält und
danach aus dem staub macht im grunde ist
der name till eulenspiegel in diesen
alten anekdoten eben nicht ein name
deiner figur anhängt sondern eher etwas
was man für eine bestimmte art von
witzen verwendet hat so wie man sagt so
wie man in osteuropa radio eriwan witze
erzählt hat und gesagt hat radio er
radio eriwan hat berichtet im prinzip ja
aber es ist anders
oder wie man wie man wie man schotten
witze erzählt das ist dann auch nicht
der gleiche schotte in diesem wissen
sondern es ist man hätte nicht die
punktgenau man hätte nicht gesagt ein
mann geht in eine vase und man hätte
gesagt die leute spiegel geht in eine
bar und diese anekdoten vereint dass sie
ein sehr dass sie alle zu tun haben also
erzählen von jemandem der sich nicht in
den zivilisations prozess an einpasst
das ist ja schon mal extrem interessant
weil ich tatsächlich diesen eindruck so
stark von dieser figur kriege das ist
nicht einfach ein netter
das ist nicht einfach ein lustiger spaß
so etwas sondern das ist auch ein
spötter system zyniker sie haben das
wort auch soziale ziele genannt
und das kommt ja gleich am anfang des
buches auch schon voraus dieser till
eulenspiegel auf den saal steht und da
wunderbare kunststücke vollführt und
gegen den leuten sagt jetzt wirft allem
an schulen nach mir und es gibt
eigentlich eine massenschlägerei dazu
übrigens eine alte einer tatsächlichen
spiel anekdote ist die ich verwendet
habe
die ich dann ein bisschen mehr ins
ernste drehe aber das ist eine von
wenigen park sind es aber von wenigen
von den
alten anekdoten ich tatsächlich ziemlich
eins zu eins übertragen habe und das
lustige ist aus heutiger sicht auch in
der schönen nacherzählung von erich
kästner die die vielleicht viele kennen
oder in anderen nacherzählungen es wird
gerne so dargestellt als ob till eine
art reisender volks pädagoge ist also
jemand der streiche verübt aber um den
leuten irgend etwas beizubringen um
ihnen ihre ist dann halt immer heißt
ihren egoismus zu zeigen oder um ihnen
deren arbeit zu zeigen der nach ist eben
nicht der nabel der sogenannte sondern
die leute aber das stimmt eigentlich
nicht denn im grunde was für eine nach
besteht darin dass die leute sich die
schuhe ausziehen und dann wegwerfen und
dann gibt es einen streit weil sie ihre
schuhe nicht wiederfinden im grunde
zeigt diese geschichte nicht dass die
leute narren sind sondern wie beklemmend
set in einem gespräch das ich mit ihm
hatte ein schriftsteller der auch über
theorien spiel geschrieben hat gesagt
das zeigt dass die leute damals die alle
die gleichen schuhe hatten also und das
meine ich mit asozial ziel oder der nahe
überhaupt der der der nahe in der
ursprünglichen in seiner ursprünglichen
art aufzutreten in der frühen neuzeit
eben in form von till eulenspiegel man
kann auch sagen danach in shakespeares
stücken wir mit ihm sehr verwandt ist er
meistens feste heißt manchmal hat auch
andere namen ist nicht jemand der den
leuten irgend etwas beibringt sondern es
ein spötter ist ziemlich gemeine ist
sehr gescheit und er ist jemand der
gefährlich ist weil man nie wirklich
weiß was er gleich tun wird mir fiel
dann auch noch ein dass es bei faust
zwei jahre eine szene gibt wo der
mephisto tatsächlich auch das nahe
auftritt wir sehen will kommt freak als
mephisto danach und der teufel die
scheinen zumindest bei goethe verwandt
zu sein aber sie sagen jetzt die sind
immer verwahren dieser in den ländlichen
lustigen ihre meinung noch gar nicht
doch aber der lustige nach ist auch ein
bisschen der gemeinde und der böse nach
die die die schellen kappe die wir die
bei uns auf den illustrationen till
immer hat die wir auch andere narren
haben den klassenraum die mütze mit dem
glöckchen
kommt von den tierhaaren her das heißt
im grunde hat der teufelshörner und auch
diese narren gewandt dass er trägt ist
eine art gewandeltes tier gewandt und
und der teufel in diesen alten
darstellungen mit als der gehörnte ist
auch jemand der noch halb tier ist und
also es gibt einen sehr schönen aufsatz
über den über den über die narrenfigur
von cg jung wo er sagt die arche das
archetyp ische der archetyp der hier in
der sich verbirgt hinter der narrenfigur
und das ist eigentlich sogar noch älter
als die teufels figur als archetyp ist
der mensch der sich nicht ganz vom tier
getrennt hat also die angst die wir
davor haben dass ein teil von uns
tierisch ist und da gehört eben das
hinein was ich mit asozial umschreiben
will dass der nach jemand ist der an
dieser tier hat auch noch näher ist und
dadurch man weiß nicht was er tun wird
man kann sich nicht darauf verlassen
dass er sich innerhalb der sozialen
regeln verhält und das ist lustig aber
das ist immer auch bedrohlich und sie
haben auch gesagt es ist missverständnis
zu meinen dass dieses aufklärerische des
narren immer spielt also das ist
eigentlich so das bild das man hat der
kommt und preist die frau ein gesicht
und hab dahinter erkennen wir was
eigentlich da wäre und sie sagen nein
manchmal ist das auch einfach so ein
spiel um seiner selbst willen und
trotzdem würden wir waschen nicht denken
es gibt so was wie die narren in unserer
gesellschaft die dazu da sind um
erkennen zu lachen uns erkennen zu
lassen wie es wirklich ist ja aber das
ist schon eine sehr neue auf neue also
auch schon 2 300 jahre alt aber eine
aufklärerische interpretation der
narrenfigur einerseits finde ich das
natürlich völlig in ordnung aber
andererseits ist es mir dann auch eben
zu pädagogisch das heißt es ist denn die
der narr und das geht bis heute das geht
bis zu den guten comedians bis zu den
bis zu den guten kabarettisten ist nicht
einfach nur bloß jemand der auf lustige
weise vernunft verbreitet sondern es
gibt eben immer auch einen wenn man so
will eine
mehrwert an wahnsinn und die wirklich
guten comedians kabarettisten von heute
haben das auch wirkliches kabarett hat
eben dann doch ja das was ich einen
überschuss an wahnsinn nennen würde auch
noch und worin bestätigt überschuss an
waren sind dass es eben auch witze gibt
die böse sind die gemein sind und die
keine pädagogischen die keinen
pädagogischen sinn haben welchen sinn
haben sie dann ja dann musste man sehr
weit ausholen in die theorie des humor
ist da habe ich gar nichts dagegen aber
die eben vor allem den sinn haben wenn
sie überhaupt erst mal gar keinen sinn
haben aber wenn sie einen abend oder
wenn man das als sinn sehen möchte dann
eine eine allgemeine verunsicherung eine
allgemeine schüttere humor wenn er
wirklich funktioniert ist eben immer
auch eine erschütterung unserer vernunft
eigentlich also mir gefällt sehr
schopenhauers theorie dass humor humors
der sagt er etwas ist dann komisch wenn
es in einem gesichtspunkt vollkommen
also wenn ein begriff und einem
gesichtspunkt vollkommen unter einen
anderen begriff passt und in einem
angesichts punkt überhaupt nicht
also ein ganz primitives beispiel wenn
jemand auf einer bananenschale
ausrutscht dann kollidieren hier zwei
dinge nämlich das eine ist der mensch
als physisches objekt das von jeder
kleinen bananenschale aus seiner bahn
geschleudert werden kann und auf einer
anderen seite der mensch als
vernünftiges wesen das die welt sieht
und versteht und mathematik und
philosophie betreiben kann und das kann
von einer bananenschale aus der bahn
geworfen werden und man hat ja eine
kollision zwischen den beiden arten
vernünftig den menschen zu sehen und das
ist lustig wie gesagt die bananenschale
ist ein einfaches beispiel sehr lustig
ist es nicht aber im grunde wenn sie gut
gemacht ist wenn wenn gute schauspieler
es macht ist es immer noch lustig aber
im grunde läuft humor immer auf diese
diskrepanz hinaus dass wir sehen unser
verstand unsere vernunft können die welt
begreifen und zu gleich gar nicht und
diese das ist eben das anarchische
potenzial der der von des humors nun
sind sie aber auch eine person die
unglaublich gerne politische satire
guckt ja so dass betonen sie auch immer
wieder zb stephen colbert ist so jemand
den sie sehr schätzen mit seiner late
show und da würde man sich ja
wahrscheinlich jetzt was anderes
zurechtlegen als es dann wirklich
politische satire und würden die daten
sagen dass ich einfach nur dieser wir
haben die erstgenannte vernunft
überschüssen überschuss von wahnsinn
nicht wirklich toll hat das zb also bei
colbert ist manches würde ich trotzdem
eher eine wichtige auf tierische rolle
hat in amerikanischen öffentlichkeit
jetzt ist trotzdem vieles was er macht
einfach nur absurd und slapstick und und
zweckfreie albernheit und und und nicht
einfach nur pädagogisch also er hat das
wobei man natürlich sagen muss die dinge
die lage wie sie im moment ist zwingt
den auch in eine bestimmte richtung also
ich glaube
einerseits ist natürlich ganz wichtig
was er tut aber andererseits zwingt ihn
die lage auch ein bisschen als volks
aufklärer tätig zu sein
in einer weise die ich meine er ist ein
wirklich es ist eigentlich genial was er
macht aber ich glaube er könnte noch
genialer sein wenn die lage ein bisschen
weniger furchtbar wäre punkten die uns
doch ganz kurz eine stelle an aus der
late show
da macht er sich lustig über einen tweet
von donald trump abgesetzt hat als
kommentar als rechtfertigung für seine
migrationspolitik und die familien
trennung und dies dann in der folge
gaben
köhler machte hier lustig über die
integrationspolitik über die familien
separierung die sehr viel zu reden kann
und tut ein bisschen so als wäre
sozusagen die ganze frage der visa
bestimmungen ein bisschen wie ein genie
das system wo man sich bewerben kann und
dann etwas gewinnen und schlussendlich
landet man im käfig im schlechteren fall
was genau ist jetzt sozusagen niemand ob
er jetzt als modernen narren sehen
würden
was ist narretei daran naja nachteil ist
natürlich dass er dinge die er selber
sehr ernst nimmt weil er findet das
natürlich überhaupt nicht lustig wenn
kinder da in käfige gesperrt werden
dass er sie so präsentiert dass sie auch
nicht wirklich lustig sind sondern dass
sie mit witz präsentiert werden also ich
finde das publikum lacht immer ein
bisschen zu viel wenn er zu solchen
wirklich brutal schrecklichen themen
kommt dafür kann er aber nichts das ist
die situation die allgemeinen die leute
bezahlen sie sitzen da sie wollen lachen
aber was er sehr gut macht es
tatsächlich das was was auch schiller
beschreibt wenn er über die
verschiedenen über die strafende und die
lachende satire spricht und die strafen
der satire bei schiller ist eben die die
zeigt dass die welt furchtbar ist die
welt wir haben ein ideal und wir haben
eine welt und die welt ist anders als
das ideal um so zu sagen manchmal mehr
manchmal weniger
in unseren zeiten gerade besonders ist
die welt anders als das ideal und
schiller sagt damit die strafende satire
funktioniert kann muss das lachen in
pathos umschlagen und das macht cool wer
tatsächlich das heißt er macht das oft
dass er wirklich gute witze macht zu
themen zu dingen die gerade passiert
sind
und dann dann dann spricht er aber nach
so darüber für ein paar minuten das dem
publikum auch das lachen vergeht und er
wird dann auch selber ernst und das ist
er dem dem inhalt ja auch angemessen und
ja dass das dass er das gefühl dafür hat
wann das angebracht ist das zeigt ihm
dass er so gut ist als satire
jetzt könnte man aber die sache ja auch
umdrehen und viele sagen ja auch noch
moment vielleicht ist auch der
eigentliche name in dieser ganzen
geschichte
donald trump der uns ein stück weit auch
an der nase herumführte sich nämlich so
aufführt als wäre jeden die eine
kostbare figur immer gleiche aussprache
die gleichen irgendwie arten sich ein
bisschen deplatziert auch zu bewegen
oder zu benehmen aber das ist alles
absicht das ist teil der inszenierung
der ist gar nicht so sondern der hat
eben im griff aus seiner politischen
situation ein spiel zu machen und uns an
der nase herumzuführen
was haben sie von dieser interpretation
ja ich finde die nicht gut weil ich
finde diese interpretation die ich ja
auch oft höre geht ein bisschen vorbei
eben daran was der nachher ist was
donald trump schon ist ist eine
vollkommen unernste figur ist jemand dem
anteil der überhaupt soweit wir das
wissen
ein ein sehr reduziertes seelenleben hat
er ist eine komische eine witzfigur in
vieler hinsicht und die tatsache dass
witzfiguren ungeheuren schaden anrichten
können
das hat eigentlich auf eine wunderbare
art beute auf den punkt gebracht wenn er
von den kirchlichen frömmler die leute
auf den scheiterhaufen bringen
er nennt die einmal afrika an propos
frage also fleisch fressen
menschenfressende harlekin und das eine
ganz tolle beobachtung oder ein toller
hinweis nämlich die menschen die
furchtbaren schaden anrichten müssen
aber selber keine profunden oder auch
nur ernst zu nehmenden leute sein sind
sie oft überhaupt nicht es sind harlekin
aber sie sind menschenfresser und donald
trump ist so ein menschenfressende
harlekin aber der name als als der name
ist per definitionem würde ich schon
sagen machtlos der narr ist nicht jemand
der macht ergreift oder auch nur will er
ist jemand der ein außenseiter ist und
wenn er die macht hat hört er auf ein
nahe zu sein also dass donald trump eine
witzfigur ist macht ihn nicht in diesem
alten traditionsreichen sind zum narren
wobei das verhältnis zwischen nah und
macht ist ja auch wiederum ein
ambivalentes weil der till ist ja schon
in seiner art und weise mächtig einige
stellen
am interessantesten finde in dem buch
ist da wo er dieses beispiel oder dieses
diesen witz mit der weißen leinwand
bringt weil er der list jugend der
winterkönigin gibt ja eine weiße
leinwand und rät ihr die anstelle eines
gemäldes an die wand zu hängen und den
leuten die da kommen um die gemälde da
zu sehen
zusagen nur die dummen leute sie nichts
oder das arme gesinde oder die leute die
irgendwie unehelich geboren sind nämlich
geboren ja das ist tatsächlich habe ich
dass es ich würde dann oft gefragt ob
das ein kommentar von mir zu modernen
kunst ist und gottes wird oder ob ich da
von yasmina reza beeinflusst bin ja so
ein wunderbares stück geschrieben hat
dass kunst heißt über eine weiße
leinwand
die wahrheit ist das ist tatsächlich mit
einer ausnahme einer einzigen wendung
von mir eins zu eins übernommen aus der
alten anekdotensammlung aus dem späten
mittelalter der anfang auch mit dem
schmerz
viel hängt da ein bild an die wand und
sagt also der der echte alte nicht meint
hill und sagt also echte also in der
anekdote und sagt dumme und niedrig
geborene und unehrliche können hier
nicht sehen die die anderen sehen ein
schönes bild und genau das macht er bei
mir es gibt aber bei mir natürlich eine
andere eine wendung dazu und das ist
eine art eine wendung die damit zu tun
hat wie ein hof funktioniert oder mit
höfische gesellschaft natürlich wissen
alle dass er hier nur eine bei mir dass
er hier noch eine weiße leinwand an die
wand gehängt hat dh in der alten
spätmittelalterlichen geschichte denkt
jeder oh mein gott ich bin dumm oder
unehrlich geboren ich muss so tun als ob
ich hier was er bei mir ist es so jeder
weiß was der nachher gemacht hat aber
gleichzeitig ist niemand ganz sicher
dass alle anderen das auch wissen genau
ja beginnt doch die macht da nur weil
sie vorhin gesagt haben danach hat quasi
keine macht ich finde thiele hat eben
auf seine art und weise ganz subtil
unglaublich viel macht zb link des im
jahr
dieses ehepaar den winter die
winterkönigin und diesen böhmischen
könig höher da ein stück weit ein
bisschen zu entzweien weil er sich ja
dann immer fragt ob sie eigentlich
wirklich gegriffen hat und da wird ja
konstruktiv aber es geht eigentlich um
macht
spiel er weiß ganz genau wo ja welche
art von swiss zählen kann indem er so
mit ein bisschen einen vorschuss hat
doch dann vielleicht auch an vertrauen
den er hat
wenn sie das alles macht sehen wollen
dann habe ich natürlich nichts dagegen
aber es ist keine macht innerhalb der
institution das ist die macht eines
außenseiters der schon ohne besonderen
grund also auch nicht um den leuten
etwas beizubringen sondern einfach so
manipulieren kann manipuliert wie die
menschen denken was für systemen sie
gefangen sind
es ist trotzdem für mich das gegenteil
von dem was jemand wie donald trump
macht aber ich meine vielleicht ist es
ja auch nur so dass ich will dann doch
zu gerne mag und irgendwie mail von
trump zurück wurde auf jeden fall ist
das system sehr intelligent und ich
glaube nicht dass trump intelligentes
ich glaube trump hat einen sehr viel
sicheren instinkt aber sonst ist er
einfach ja wie schon gesagt ein dummkopf
und entwickeln ich wollte es auch nicht
diese parallel weiter treiben sondern
mehr das verhältnis zwischen narreteien
gemacht ausleuchten vielleicht noch eine
frage zu traum falls sie noch einmal
bringen es ist ja wirklich so wenn man
interviews mit ihnen liest dann merkt
man dass ihnen was wirklich auch ein
anliegen ist immer wieder darauf zu
sprechen zu kommen dass diese politik in
den usa wir leben in den usa primär dass
das für sie etwas ganz ganz schrecklich
es ist wenn das da gerade abläuft gibt
es nicht auch momente wo sie zweifeln wo
sie denken ist eigentlich auch verrückt
jetzt gibt eigentlich die gesamte sagen
mal intelligenz jahr ist geschlossen
gegen kramm ist das nicht auch na ja ein
bisschen gefährlich oder vielleicht fast
schon nein nein also ich meine zweifel
ist immer gut man soll nicht gegen
zweifel seien es ist immer gut sich zu
fragen habe ich eigentlich recht oder
haben vielleicht die die anderer meinung
sind recht das ist nie falsch aber es
ist im fall trumps so absolut eindeutig
jeder einzelne jeder einzelne tag jede
einzelne woche bringt irgend etwas
furchtbares also ich würde mal sagen wer
durch duell durch einen hier eineinhalb
jahre der entsetzlich keiten noch nicht
überzeugt ist den muss doch da nun
wirklich überzeugt haben wenn
heraus kam dass er kinder von den eltern
trennen lässt und noch glücklich an der
grenze und noch und das noch ganz
richtig findet und wenn das noch nicht
überzeugt dass hier etwas furchtbares
vorgeht und dass die demokratie in
amerika in einer ganz großen gefahr ist
und damit auch die demokratien der
westlichen welt wäre davon nicht
überzeugt ist mit dem sehe ich auch
keinen gesprächsmöglichkeit mehr
das heißt einerseits ist es natürlich
immer richtig sich zu fragen habe ich
vielleicht unrecht haben die anderen
recht aber andererseits darf man auch
über diese grundsätzlichen bereitschaft
zu zweifeln nicht bereit seien
grundsätze allzu sehr in frage zu
stellen an die man einfach glaubt und
die selbstverständlich sein müssen
irgendwann muss man auch sagen hier sind
die verhältnisse wirklich so klar wie
sie überhaupt nur sein können wenn man
sie so sprechen hört dann merkt man sie
sind ein enorm politischer mensch der
sich auch gerne äußert zurzeit geschehen
und dann stellt sich ja manchmal auch
vielleicht die frage warum ist dieser
daniel kehlmann eigentlich einer der
sich so gerne in die vergangenheit rein
gräbt wenn er romane schreibt das war
auch eine frau die übrigens die mir auf
facebook gestellt wurde hatte ich da
geschrieben habe dass ich sie treffe
warum schreibt eigentlich nie einen
science fiction oder etwas zugegen war
auch zur gegenwart habe ich aber
geschrieben also meinen roman ruhe zum
beispiel den ich nach der vermessung der
welt geschrieben habe handelt man muss
dann unter den bedingungen von 2008 9 wo
ich ihn geschrieben weil paket ganz
stark von elektronischer kommunikation
und auch sozialen medien
also das ist zum beispiel ein wirklich
nicht nur in gegenwart roman sondern
einen roman auch über die gegenwart das
gleiche mit dem oder nicht ganz so stark
aber der roman f den ich nachher
geschrieben habe der handelte zu einem
großen teil von der finanzkrise von 2008
also man wird immer definiert von den
anderen als das durch das was der größte
erfolg ist und das war die vermessung
der welt nach der ich eigentlich gesagt
habe ich will keinen historischen roman
mehr schreiben
jetzt habe ich es noch einmal gemacht
und dann werde ich eben gefragt warum
nicht mal was zur gegenwart ich habe
alle andere alle anderen bücher sind in
der gegenwart angesiedelt
es ist schon wahr dass mich geschichte
sehr beschäftigt und interessiert also
ich merke schon auch
dass es etwas am erzählen von
geschichten gibt was mir sehr liegt wo
ich das gefühl habe sie geht mich auch
an also dieses diese vielzitierte satz
von von von vor knapp dass die dass die
vergangenheit nicht vergangen ist ist
tatsächlich mein auch mein gefühl ich
habe dass ich habe nicht das gefühl wenn
ich im dreißigjährigen krieg erzählen
dass hier eine art mit einer art
zeitkapsel betrete von einer ganz ganz
fernen versunkenen welt sondern ich habe
das gefühl dass da wenn ich mich damit
beschäftige dass das auf eine gewisse
weise für mich lebendig ist und lebendig
wird das ist einfach und vielleicht muss
ich das auch einfach über mich selbst
akzeptieren da muss ja auch man lernt ja
auch wo die eigenen hände doch ein
missstand man müsste sechs aus
tschechien
sie können das ja einfach wahnsinnig gut
weswegen sie die die bücher so
erfolgreich und war wird ja nicht nur
diese zeit plastisch über die ich
nachher gleich noch mit ihnen sprechen
möchte sondern es werden auch ganz viele
probleme plastisch von denen ich glaube
dass sie schon lange beschäftigen
ich möchte mit ihnen über den vater
sprechen von till eulenspiegel das ist
eigentlich meine lieblingsfigur der
klaus denn klaus ist eigentlich müller
wiederwählen
er ist in erster linie ein denker und
erbauer und ganz große probleme zu lösen
zum beispiel das sogenannte haufen
paradox haufen bei hausen paradox oder
das sogenannte jury das problem gab es
ja schon in der antike und er zieht sich
zurück mit solchen haufen körnern in den
estrich und möchte herausfinden wieviel
körner kann hier weg nehmen ohne dass
das ihr aufhört ein haufen zu sein
und da stellt fest er verzweifelt man
fast dass man kann ganz viel wechselte
und trotzdem haben wir immer noch eher
in die hier entsteht jetzt ein haufen ob
das hier noch ein hoffentlich wissen wir
nicht
warum kein triviales problem jetzt hat
auch ehrlich gesagt gibt es gibt
unterschiedliche lösungen die auch jetzt
noch eine lösung von der man merkt es
stimmt wir ganz genau und man muss es
sich komischerweise wird das ist nicht
trivial ist merkt man mehr noch stärker
wenn man sich umgekehrt vorstellen wenn
man sagt man man legt nun ein korn hier
hin dass es natürlich kein haufen dann
legt man ein zweiter sind es ist
natürlich kein haufen
irgendwann muss es das
eine kochen geben bei dem das hier
beginnt ein haufen zu sein
oder anders gesagt zum beispiel wenn man
einen ganz wenn man einen tisch machen
möchte und man tut immer holz dazu aber
nur ein fingernagel menge an holz ab
wann hat man genug holz für einen tisch
es gibt die unterschiedlichsten
formulierungen man kann natürlich sagen
eben haufen oder tisch oder werke sind
unklare begriffe etwas es gibt einen
ganzen verschwommenen bereich wo man
selber definieren kann wo man was das
nun ist ist das nur ein haufen oder
nicht aber es ist kein triviales problem
nein es ist kein triviales problem und
das interessante ist ja auch was
passiert eigentlich mit diesem klassiker
klaus wird gefoltert und schlussendlich
gehängt von der inquisition weil er
eigentlich allzu viel wissen will
zumindest befasst dass ich mit bücher
die die inquisition nicht gut findet
kann man davon irgendwie lernen wenn wir
zu viel wissen wollen dann droht das
verderben
das ist immer so ja natürlich darauf an
was wir wissen wollen niemandem droht
heute das verderben weil er weil er zu
viel über mathematik wissen möchte aber
es gibt immer bereiche wo es gefährlich
ist zu viel wissen zu wollen
und es gab zeiten wo das natürlich noch
viel mehr so wahr und und die freiheit
zu denken die freiheit zu reden die
freiheit sich zu beschäftigen womit man
möchte ist ziemlich neu in der
geschichte und das heißt für den für die
meisten menschen die je gelebt haben war
das nicht selbstverständlich ist und
natürlich wird klaus und spiegeln bei
mir ja auch er wird dann nicht
verurteilt dafür dass er zu viel wissen
wollte sondern er wird als als er wird
als ketzer und in folge davon dann auch
als hexer verurteilt nicht ganz
natürlich zu unrecht weil sowas gab es
einen gibt es nicht aber nicht ganz
unbegründet weil er tatsächlich mit
wissen dass es sich erworben hat auch
heilungen durchgeführt hat oder kranken
geholfen hat und also es ist natürlich
auch in einer worum es mir auch mit der
figur ganz stark gingen die figur ist
auch inspiriert von einem großartigen
buch von dem historiker carlo ginzburg
das heißt der käse und die würmer da hat
er tatsächlich
in italien einen investitions fall
untersucht wo ein müller auch von der
inquisition hingerichtet wurde für seine
wissbegierde also dass es waren sehr oft
müller
das ist kein zufall es waren oft müller
weil mühlen ein bisschen weiter weg vom
dorf lagen müller war auch ein zum teil
ehrloser beruf also konnte nicht
wirklich teil der dorfgemeinschaft
werden und die haben dann angefangen
häufig sich als heiler zu betätigen sich
als magier zu betätigen sich mit dingen
zu beschäftigen und es ist ein ganz
wichtiger geist mein klaus ulenspiegel
aber jemand der unter umständen lebt wo
er keine möglichkeiten hat wissen zu
erwerben
niemand wird etwas beibringen niemand
wird ihm helfen er ist praktisch mit
seiner wissbegier alleine in der welt
und deswegen versucht er sich selber
eine art system zusammen zu bauen
und wenn jetzt diese wissbegier immer
noch vielleicht herauslösen aus dieser
zeit auch noch bestraft wurde von der
inquisition wenn man dinge wissen wollte
ja eigentlich nichts angingen oder von
dem andenken wie das wird irgendwie
richtung teufels kult um nur die
wissbegierde heraus nehmen dann glaube
ich laden wir doch bei einem thema was
sie immer wieder beschäftigt haben in
ihrem ersten roman bos vorstellungen
geht es auch um eine person dabei holm
der gerne in mathematik verstehen möchte
er verzweifelt unter anderem an der
frage warum man eigentlich die zahl nun
nicht teilen kann oder auch geister in
princeton ein theaterstück von ihnen
oder mahlers zeit lauter texte von ihnen
da geht immer um dieses ringen mit
dieser mathematik um das ringen auch
dass wir gewisse dinge nicht wissen
können und da musste ich an emanuel kaum
denken an die vorräte zur kritik der
reinen vernunft wo er sagt die
menschliche natur hat dieses schicksal
dieses besondere schicksal von fragen
belästigt zu werden die sie nie lösen
kann aber die ich auch nicht loswerden
kann ist dieses ringen etwas was sie
selber umtreibt
ja natürlich also ich finde ich auf
meinem laienhaften niveau natürlich ohne
mathematik zu verstehen ohne die
dahinterstehende mathematik zu verstehen
beschäftige ich versuche ich
einigermaßen zu verstehen was in der
quantenphysik gerade passiert heute oder
was in den letzten jahren passiert ist
und
es kann einem ganz verrückt machen weil
die dinge die hier die wir hier
beobachten über die welt im unendlich
ihm nicht unendlich haben fast unendlich
kleinen so verwirrend sind und so
paradox und so und ja man kann schon
sagen unbegreiflich aber sie passieren
und sie sind messbar dass es einen
eigentlich ich kann zum beispiel nicht
die achseln zucken und sagen ja das ist
interessant und oder es ist ganz
interessant aber was soll's sondern ich
habe das gefühl das ist wirklich eine
persönliche tragik ist dass ich sterben
werde ohne dass man diese paradoxe und
rätsel aufgelöst hat und natürlich wird
das so sein weil das man wird sie
wahrscheinlich und unter umständen
auflösen unter umständen ist unser
kenntnis apparat gar nicht gemacht um
die welt im extrem kleinen oder extrem
großen zu verstehen
möglicherweise ist die welt gar nicht
verstehe da in diesen in diesem land
dimensional irgendwie ich empfinde das
als tragisch ja also ich finde verstehen
wollen ist schon also sagen wir mal dass
das dass das lustige ist dass es für
mich gar nicht so schlimm wenn ich das
nicht verstehen aber das wissen dass
niemand das recht von uns allen der
menschheit das ist wirklich schlimm
also ich finde der der wunsch verstehen
zu wollen jetzt gar nicht unbedingt in
jedem einzelnen aber in der menschheit
als ganzes und unsere welt besser zu
verstehen der ja auch fortschritt
hervorbringt der der motor des
fortschritts ist der wirkliche motor des
fortschrittes ist ja nicht dass wir
irgendwo schneller hin wollen und dann
fängt man an schnellere autos zu
entwickeln sondern es ist dass man
grundsatz forschung betreibt und
irgendwann kommen als rand produkt sogar
mal schneller autos dabei heraus dieses
das definiert die menschheit und das ist
auch etwas wirklich ganz
grossartiges worüber ich mich nie lustig
machen würde also die vermessung der
welt ist ja auch zum großen zu einem
großen teil einer komödie
aber es ist mir kalt und grau ja das
müssen nicht erst mal noch nachreichen
also wer naturwissenschaftler
mathematiker genau und es ist ein über
naturwissenschaftler mathematiker und
der eine reist und versucht die welt zu
verstehen im reisen im sammeln von daten
und der andere versucht das im denken
und es ist eine komödie aber über dieses
verstehen wollen würde ich mich nie
lustig machen das finde ich was ganz
großes
ich verstehe sie gar in unglaublich gut
und ich habe mir überlegt ob wir nicht
sagen kann es gibt vielleicht
verschiedene therapieformen höchster
verzweiflung zu gehen
eine therapieform kann mir vielleicht
sagen ist es ein nahezu werden oder ein
bauplatz zu sein oder ein zauberer also
sozusagen auszuweichen in das verspielte
hinein
vielleicht macht das auch der telis
macht es auf jeden fall der bären in
ihrem buch behrens vorstellung und das
macht jeder künstler in gewisser weise
genauso sie selber zaubern ja auch aber
sie wollten keine zaubertricks vorführen
zwischen großem leid richtig ich hatte
gesagt ich kann ich kann im fernsehen
keine zaubertricks vorführen
ich habe lange nicht gezaubert ich habe
tatsächlich ganz gut dass ich kann das
jetzt natürlich leicht behaupten weil
ich es nicht beweisen muss aber ich habe
bis ungefähr 21 lebensjahr wirklich ganz
gut gezaubert und wenn ich das dann
weiter verfolgt hätte hätte ich
vielleicht noch den punkt erreicht wo
man tatsächlich hätte auftreten können
also wo ich das unter umständen in einem
anderen leben in einem paralleluniversum
vielleicht sogar zu einem beruf hätte
machen können
ich habe dann stattdessen meinen roman
geschrieben wir haben vorstellungen über
einen zauberkünstler und seltsamerweise
ohne dass ich das geplant hatte war das
dann für mich in gewisser weise erledigt
also ich hab dann nicht mehr geübt also
ich habe nicht mehr gezaubert ich habe
manchmal noch freunden was gezeigt aber
ich habe mich nicht mehr so ernsthaft
damit beschäftigt ich habe aber noch
genug
ich fühle mich noch genug zugehörig und
auch verbunden der der kunstform der der
zauberkunst und ich würde sagen wenn das
leute wird nicht mehr das gut machen ist
das eine
kunstform dass ich nicht auf laienhafte
niveau kunststücke zeigen weil das
problem ist wenn man zum beispiel ein
schlechtes gedicht schreibt oder ein
schlechtes bild malt dann hat man sich
nur selber blamiert man steht dann
selber schlecht da wenn man ein
zauberkunststück schlecht zeigt dann
sehen dann verstehen die zuschauer ja
wie das geht und dann hat man nicht nur
sich blamiert sondern auch die guten
zauberer die das kunststück vielleicht
demnächst zeigen weil dann sagen sie ja
ich weiß wie das geht und man hat für
andere den trick ruiniert und aus dem
grund für ich öffentlich keine
zauberkunststücke vor
ich habe das gefühl das ist meine wer
eine echte professionelle verbundenheit
die ich noch zu dem mädchen habe ist
dass ich für andere keine tricks
ruinieren jetzt werden wir mal davon
ausgehen dass vielleicht zauberei oder
kunst eine art eben wäre der therapie
des unvermögens die welt zu verstehen
kann er noch sagen es gibt vielleicht
die zweite vor unserem therapie und das
wäre die flucht in den glauben
das kommt ja auch vor der bär holding
zuerst gläubig und auch bei viel kommt
das vor und da sind wir eigentlich bei
meiner zweiten lieblingsfigur nämlich
tatsächlich bei diesem doktor kirche
nach einer der jesuiten und am schönsten
finde ich auch dass dieser jesuit auch
das konto logi betrat das müssen sie
schon zu erklären also habe ich nicht
gefunden
das ist das erstaunliche überhaupt ja
das war tatsächlich ein man kann aus
heutiger sicht würde man sagen ein
wissenschaftszweig oder eben
wissenschaft hat man so das wort nicht
verwendet sondern hätte gesagt das ist
ein bereich der gelehrsamkeit in der
frühen neuzeit und das war die lehre der
drachen die wissenschaft von den drachen
und im grunde weil die leute waren ja
auch nicht blöd die leute wussten schon
sie haben keine drachen zur verfügung
war es die lehre von der substitution
also man der drache war denn hat man
geht man hat den drachen als ein
perfektes lebewesen gesehen dessen
körper in jeder hinsicht ungeheure
heilkraft besitzt drachenblut würde dann
wäre dann sozusagen der der heilige gral
der medizin das würde einen unsterblich
machen oder von
krankheiten heilen genau dabei mir
wildkirsche damit die pest heil und
mittelalterliche oder eben
frühneuzeitliche medizin funktioniert
ganz stark nach diesem alchemistischen
prinzip der ähnlichkeit wenn etwas heil
dann heilen auch dinge die diesen dingen
ähnlich sehen und dinge heilen das dem
sie ähnlich sehen eine blume die
aussieht werden auge wird gegen
augenkrankheiten eingesetzt zum beispiel
und dh der truck on two logo hat drachen
körperteile also müssen die geschockte
haut des drachen durch bestimmte
baumrinden oder substituiert die dann
heilkraft haben weil sie dem drachen
ähnlich sehen das ist die 3 konsole
genauso sagen wesen des drachens
studieren wenn wir es ganz genau
wörtlich verstehen aber das lustigste
schaffe ich es ja dass das sie sofort zu
gestehen diese entwickeln wird noch nie
ein brauchen gesehen zu hören man kennt
auch kein darlehen braucht und das ist
ja der beweis dafür dass es brauchen
gibt denn das eigentliche wesensmerkmal
des drachen
das ist gut versteckt genau das ist ja
also das ist ja unglaublich komisch das
ist natürlich von mir also diese
argumentation habe ich so nicht in alten
quellen gefunden
aber diese argumentation habe ich sehr
oft gefunden im grunde argumentieren
ganz viele alternativen mediziner auf
diese art wenn man mit dieser
schwierigen theorien auch
verschwörungstheorien auch genau weil es
keine beweise gibt dass man keine
beweise finde zeigt nur wie wahnsinnig
gut die verschwörung ist das sind alles
varianten von dem was karl popper die
immunisierung strategie nennt also oder
eben ja wie gesagt in der in der in der
alternativ medizin wo einem dann auch
wieder gesagt wird das ist klinische mit
dass es in klinischen studien nicht
gezeigt werden kann es vielmehr beweis
wie gut das funktioniert und es hat mir
natürlich sehr viel spaß gemacht damit
zu spielen in der argumentation dieser
dieser konto logen und ist nicht das
eben auch ein versuch mit dem wahnsinn
der welt respektive mit dieser sache
sagen verhüllung strategie der welt
gegen sieben nicht möglich macht sie
wirklich zu durchdringen mit der von uns
umzugehen dass er so waren sie die
wahnwitzige gebäude finden ja es ist
eine möglichkeit aber es ist eine
möglichkeit der mann natürlich wieder
stehen wo es so wie man
verschwörungstheorien widerstehen muss
sondern die große aufgabe besteht darin
ein vernünftiger mensch zu sein die
große aufgabe an jedem von uns besteht
darin sich nicht von diesen labyrinthen
von immunisierung strategien einfangen
zu lassen
denn natürlich kann man es das ganze hat
ja deswegen ist es auch komisch um noch
mal auf schuhhaus theorie des humors
zurückzukommen
es hat eine es stimmt ja in gewisser
weise als argumentation und in anderer
stimmt es überhaupt nicht wenn man
voraussetzt dass drachen sich so gut
verstecken können dann ist tatsächlich
die tatsache dass man keinen drachen
gefunden hat ein beweis dafür wie gut
sie sich verstecken können aber die
lösung dieses rätsels ist natürlich
nicht dass man dann die kirche das macht
einen drachen dort sucht wo es überhaupt
noch nie einen drachen sichtung gegeben
weil der sich habe es auch ganz gut
verstanden haben das gut versteckt
sondern die lösung ist natürlich dass
man es vernünftiger mensch sagt es gibt
keine drachen und das heißt sie haben
recht es ist ein ausweg aber es ist ein
falscher auswege sind ausweg den man
widerstehen muss und nicht immer sind
die so offensichtlich das heißt wir
verstecken uns ganz oft in solche
wahngebilde die gar nicht so offen als
wahre bild erkennbar sind
ich frage mich manchmal wenn man noch
einmal dieses bild vom kann nimmt das
hier belästigt wir haben durch fragen
die uns die vernunft auf gibt die aber
nicht lösen können
ob uns die welt irgendwie wissen zum
narren hält er hat in frage stelle ich
mir stellt man sich öfter also
ss oder bzw dieser schöne gedanke diesen
schönen gedanken / ich mal formuliert
dass wenn man sich mit quantenphysik
beschäftigt es gibt wenn man
computerspiele spielt sagt er natürlich
ein schöner gedanke ich wünschte der von
mir wenn man computerspiele spielen
haben viele gedanken kommt man manchmal
wenn man irgendwo stehen bleibt oder
irgendwo hin schaut wo das nicht
vorgesehen war vom punkt vom computer
programmierer dann findet man manchmal
so orte wo das nicht wo das nicht weiter
ausgeführt wurde wo die realität
praktisch löcher hat wo man doch
irgendwie dass das das koordinaten netz
findet also wo man einfach merkt hier
ist die realität löchrig ist die nicht
ausgeführt einfach weil der
programmierer nie gedacht hat dass das
man hier stehen bleiben und an dem ort
zum beispiel auf den boden sehen wird
oder sowas und schecks so ist das ein
bisschen mit quantenphysik
es war sozusagen nie vorgesehen dass wie
also wenn man die welt religiös ansehen
wollte würde man sagen diese ganz
kleinen dimensionen das hat gott nicht
geplant dass wir uns das anschauen
und deswegen hat das nicht ausgeführt
und wir sehen hier praktisch etwas und
attacken gott bei etwas was ihm ein
bisschen peinlich ist wohl das gefühl
das ist das war nicht vorgesehen dass
ihr das seht und um das ist dass ich ein
schöner gedanke aber sie ist auch
natürlich nur eine eine bevor sie jetzt
denke ich bin religiös geworden wo sich
das ist natürlich nur eine metapher
das braucht nicht gerade fragen wer das
dann peinlich wäre mir das peinlich ihr
regiert zu werden ist das peinlich ich
finde für den fragen sie mich in ein
paar jahren noch mal und wie sieht das
ja immer in unterschiedlichen
lebensaltern anders aber ich habe das
gefühl das was ich gerade gesagt habe
die aufgabe im leben ist ein religiöser
es ein vernünftiger mensch zu sein würde
ich auch sagen dieser teil dieser
aufgabe ein vernünftiger mensch zu sein
ist auch dass man der verlockung durch
die einfachheit eines religiösen
weltbildes wieder steht dass man sagt
das wäre ja schön aber es ist doch
leider ein bisschen zu einfach
also lieber eine andere strategie finden
mit diesen löchern umzugehen die der
rationalität lächerlich da geht ja oder
eben die verzweiflung und unsicherheit
die daraus entsteht eben auch dass man
weiß dass diese fragen offen bleiben
dass man sterben wird ohne die antworten
erfahren zu haben dass man die auch
aushält
ja das wäre ja auch eigentlich die
antwort von alba kann wir haben
sozusagen den steinen die sie vor zwar
hoch zu holen obwohl man weiß der autor
wieder runter anfangs kann immer noch
druck waren werden den roman im sinne
von dass das di di di di sinnenfreude
genauso das wäre eine andere sublimation
sozusagen der schwierigkeit ja das ist
glaube ich das ist ja max frischs
interpretation von don juan oder die
liebe zur geometrie heißt ja so ein
stück das don juan eigentlich zum
frauenheld wird weil er so an der
geometrie verzweifelt das eine sehr
individuelle interpretation von max
frisch also ich glaube zum beispiel der
noch karten bei mozart interessiert sich
nicht für für geometrie aber ja das war
natürlich auch eine möglichkeit aber
eben er würde sich dann trotzdem noch
für geometrie interessieren und auch bei
max richter sicher dann zurück umstadt
stadt der liebe die geometrie zu
betreiben weil ihnen die dann plötzlich
noch mehr interessiert kommen wir noch
auf die zeit zu sprechen in der dieser
thiel spielt also sie haben eben in die
zeit des dreißigjährigen krieges
versetzt die schildern diese zeit also
eine zeit wie sie ja wahrscheinlich auch
war in vielen büchern auch so
geschildert wird als eine zeit des
brutalen hungers der des unglaublichen
morgens grausam ist es stinkt
unglaublich in diesem buch wenn man das
liest oder wir dann zum teil wirklich
fast übel ist türmen sich leichenberge
kinderleichen liegen überall rum was ist
wirklich grauenhaft warum haben sie so
einen düsteren plot gewählt indem sie
denn thiel versetzt haben in die
romantik versetzen können weil die zeit
vorher da war bei mir also ich wollte
über den dreißigjährigen krieg schreiben
ich wollte über diese zeit der
religionskriege schreiben und dann
dachte ich eben till oder ein name wäre
der beste führer durch diese zeit wäre
die beste figur mit der man durch diesen
figuren reigen den ich eigentlich machen
wollte
wandern könnte und dann dachte ich warum
dann nicht den typischen deutschen nach
dem warum dann nicht die leute spiele
warum nicht die neuen spiegel auch
verwenden ich habe nicht einen namen
verwendet sondern eben auch vieles aus
den aus den alten anekdoten oder einiges
aber diese zeit war das worüber ich
zuerst schreiben
ich weiß es auch nicht genau ich meine
man merkt ja nur als schriftsteller dass
eine gewisse dinge beschäftigen dass man
das gefühl hat daraus kann ich was
machen damit man sieht auch das
gegenteil sehr oft dass ich ideen habe
oder was höre oder was lese wo ich in
der zeitung wo ich denke daraus könnte
man einen tollen roman machen aber nicht
ich das ist nichts für mich und in
diesem fall
es hatte komischerweise auch sehr stark
mit einer überwindung von abneigung zu
tun
also ich habe mich ja ich hatte immer
das gefühl die kultur und
kulturgeschichte wie sie mich
interessiert beginnt im achtzehnten
jahrhundert rokoko schöne musik
aufklärerische bücher die das licht der
vernunft springt an und alles vorher ist
so ist wie sie sagen erstens
unhygienisch buchstäblich also es stinkt
es ist die menschen lebten ohne hygiene
es ist wahnsinnig verwirrend eben auch
die die politik ist wahnsinnig
verwirrend man weiß relativ wenig über
das alltagsleben aus wenn man weiß dass
es sehr schwer war
aber glauben über alleine auf die vor
aufklärerische welt hexenverfolgungen
auch ganz starke teilt dass das nicht
dass das jetzt jedem dauernd passiert
ist also dass ich will jetzt auch nicht
dass bildern das horrorkabinett zeichnen
sondern soll aber dass die die welt war
schon bestimmt von alter eben
gegenentwurf auch fasziniert zu unserer
heutigen welt
ja und es war auch eine sehr persönliche
entscheidung weil ich das gefühl hatte
johnson frentzen hat mal zu mir gesagt
und er meinte dass mehr in familiären
zusammenhang aber er meinte wenn du das
gefühl hast es gibt etwas worüber du gar
nicht schreiben möchtest aus
persönlichen gründen oder aus welchen
gründen auch immer irgendwas in deinem
leben im leben deiner familie soll erst
gemeint dann ist darf das vorzuschreiben
solltest und ich fand dass ich meine
großartigen ratschlag und bei mir was
ein bisschen somit dieser zeit ich hatte
das gefühl ich möchte mich nicht auf
diese zeit ein lassen die es mir
unangenehm die hat was albtraum artiges
die es abstoßend ich will gar nicht
anfangen in diese richtung mich
überhaupt zu beschäftigen
und ich dachte
auch stark vielleicht ist das ein
zeichen dass genau da ein teil von etwas
liegt womit ich mich genau beschäftigen
sollte und ich es ist auch kein zufall
wenn man in die deutschen mit in die
große klassische deutsche literatur
sieht dass diese zeit für die größten
deutschen für einige der größten
deutschen autoren der keim für ihre
wichtigsten werke war
in wallenstein bei schiller goethes
faust ist auch eine figur der frühen
neuzeit brechts mutter also ein gutes
haus noch ein bisschen älter als figur
aber es ist auch diese frühe neuzeit
brechts mutter courage
also man hat das gefühl es gibt etwas in
dem auch ihre oder was ich überlegt 30
jahre krieg ein viertel der bevölkerung
ist damals umgekommen in manchen
regionen die hälfte trotzdem wagen sie
zum teil dann auch den vergleich mit
heute also so ganz außerordentlich sagen
sie war diese zeit dann vielleicht doch
nicht wir sehen heute eigentlich
ähnliche sind sie machen den vergleich
zum teil mit sich also ich in die sich
dem hoch sondern wenn sie mich fragen
die werden natürlich oft darauf
angesprochen gibt es parallelen und
träumen sie manchmal auch syrien ja also
ich hatte dass ich zu meiner also ich
hab mich ich fühle mich auch bestätigt
gefühlt als herfried münklers buch dann
kurz nach meinem buch erschien herfried
münklers buch über den dreißigjährigen
krieg wo er die gleiche parallele zieht
die sich eben auch meiner meinung nach
wirklich aufdrängt und ich stimme ihm da
völlig zu syrien ist wirklich ein sehr
starkes parallel beispiel weil man auch
dieses ineinander hat von religiösen und
politischen motivation kann ist dass in
syrien ein politischer krieg kann man
nicht sagt ein religiöser krieg kann man
nicht bejahen
aber es auch kein krieg wo religion
keine rolle spielt sie ist natürlich
auch sehr starken stellvertreter krieg
in die augen zu schauen was hier
vielleicht zum teil noch weniger doch
ganz stark also dass das katholische
frankreich hat den krieg dann für fast
15 jahren noch am laufen gehalten als es
auf der seite des protestantischen
schweden eingriff damit der kaiser nicht
zu mächtig wird also es wurde dann die
zweite hälfte wurde es genauso ein
stellvertreterkrieg wie es jetzt in
syrien erleben also genau deswegen
stellt sich die parallele wirklich her
und es war natürlich auch ein krieg der
gewaltige flüchtlingswelle
ströme ausgelöst hat und da hatte ich
eben auch beim schreiben das gefühl ich
wollte ja nicht allzu sehr auf aktuelle
parallelen also ich mag das nicht wenn
in büchern der autor immer in
historischen büchern der autozum leser
hinüber zwinkert und sagt wir wissen
schon was für was für eine parallele
hinaus
er nahm nicht pädagogisch sein ich will
nicht pädagogisch sein genau
aber wenn ich darüber geschrieben wir
dass münchen die tore geschlossen hat
weil man gesagt hat wir wollen niemanden
mehr aufnehmen es geht nicht mehr und
die dann die menschen vor den
stadtmauern verendet sind
ich musste überhaupt nicht irgendwie die
parallele andeuten sie stellt sich
einfach ganz von selber her an einer
bestimmten stelle schreiben sie in den
satz was macht die erde mit all diesen
blut und ich habe mir eher die frage
gestellt oder stellen sie mir heute oft
was machen wir menschen mit all diesen
blut ja wir erinnern uns an daran auch
wenn wir es vergessen haben das ist eben
auch das was überhaupt
worauf ich mit diesem buch hinaus wollte
wenn überhaupt auf etwas das die
vergangenheit nicht vorbei ist und die
die massaker der vergangenheit sogar die
des dreißigjährigen krieges wo keine
direkte familien überlieferung mehr
besteht die wenigsten familien haben
noch eine direkte überlieferung adlige
familie natürlich weil die stammbäume
zeichnen haben die meisten familie haben
keine direkte überlieferung mehr was
ihre vorfahren damals gemacht haben aber
trotzdem habe ich das gefühl und ich
merke das auch stark in reaktionen der
menschen auf eine ganz seltsame
untergründige art ist das noch präsent
sind diese massaker des dreißigjährigen
krieges auch noch präsent und sind sogar
vorher noch die massaker der
bauernkriege präsent in deutschland oder
sind auch glaube ich in frankreich die
die religiösen kriege dass das des
jahrhunderts vorher noch präsent es gibt
und ich kann das gar nicht gut
beschreiben weil
weil man sehr schnell die jungen
psychologie kommt wenn man das wenn man
das beschreiben will aber es gibt
tiefere erinnerungs schichten wo sich
diese dinge zu halten scheinen und und
und und und sei es auch nur dadurch
merkt dass die leute plötzlich ganz
stark reagieren wenn man von diesem
vergangenen wasser kann spricht ich habe
ja auch richtig frage gestellt habe was
machen die menschen eigentlich mit all
diesen blut ein stück weit dann doch
auch wieder und heute getan weil auch
der satz was macht die erde mit all
diesen blut bezieht sich ja auch sehr
stark auf den kriegen sirion natürlich
ja natürlich
es bezieht sich auf den krieg in syrien
und in gewisser weise muss man einiges
verdrängen überhaupt noch sein leben
weiterführen zu können
man muss ja morgens sein kind in die
schule bringen oder man muss zur arbeit
gehen und man kann nicht den ganzen tag
dran denken was für furchtbare ist
gerade in der welt passiert aber man
darf auch nicht so weit gehen mit dieser
verdrängung und und ich meine natürlich
kommen wir so automatisch zur
flüchtlingskrise oder zur zur
sogenannten flüchtlingskrise die ja in
dieser hinsicht gar keine krise ist
sondern hinauf geredet wird zur krise
von von politischen kräften von
rechtspopulisten die damit auch
politisches kapital machen wollen und
wenn uns diese wenn diese verdrängung so
weit führt dass wir uns nur noch fragen
wie können wir uns abschirmen von denen
die hilfe braucht die hilfe brauchen von
denen die sterben dann ist das natürlich
absolut unakzeptabel wir haben als dass
man hat die moralische pflicht sich zu
fragen was können wir tun um den
menschen zu helfen und besonders
deutschland hat das natürlich als ein
land von dem vor nicht langer zeit
selbst gigantische flüchtlingsströme
hinausgegangen sind die man draußen
nicht nehmen wollte und es gibt auch
eine andere frage die nehme ich jetzt
einfach mit in das ende unseres
gesprächs es gibt nämlich eine stelle da
stirbt der letzte brauche ich habe mit
17.000 jahr für stirb der letzte drache
unterschreiben sie sein leben hatte lang
gedauert
nun war es zeit sich zu verwandeln das
nehme ich mit als rezept ich danke ihnen
sehr dankbar für dieses gespräch sehr
gerne
[Musik]